I forgot how to do long division.
(laughs)
Wait this, wait, wait sorry
Yeah.
Woo.
(mellow music)
Uh huh
What?
Wha-what?
Oh God.
I actually freakin' love math.
I feel like I need another shot.
I was a math major so,
I hope I can do sixth grade math still.
Very good.
Here we go.
- [Male narrator] Nancy and
her friends decide to buy
bulk fudge from the candy store.
If they bought five pounds of fudge
and each person wants five
sevenths of a pound of fudge
then how many people can
get to share the fudge?
What going on in Nancy's life,
that she needs to buy
five pounds of fudge?
This equals a whole.
This right here plus this equals a whole.
My answer is three point five.
I really want chocolate right now.
That's cheating.
Zero point three pounds.
Seven friends.
I got
seven?
It's seven.
- [Female narrator] The
correct answer is seven.
(cheering)
Seven?
What?
(Grunts)
- [Male narrator] A teacher
rewards her students with two
jujubes for every test
question they get correctly.
The test has 88 questions and
Damian got a quarter correct.
If Michaela also gave
Damian 28 of her jujubes,
how many jujubes did Damian end up with?
What are these ju jubees?
Jujubes.
I don't know what that is.
You know back when you're
in division they have the
quotent and the quotation.
The quotient?
The quo, fuck.
Is there any more in this?
It's 72?
Damn it see now that makes
a lot of freakin' sense man.
I'm going with 72.
My answer was 24.
- [Female narrator] The
correct answer is 72.
What?
(Grunting)
Oh my God, are you kidding me.
That's clearly vodka,
vodka for V.
- [Male narrator] Two trains
leave different cities
heading towards each
other at different speeds.
Train A, traveling 70 miles
per hour, leaves LA and is
heading towards Las Vegas, 260 miles away.
At the same time, train B
travels from Vegas to LA
at 60 miles per hour.
At what time do the trains meet?
Well I hate fuckin' train problems.
I know
I hate these train problems.
The worse questions start with two trains.
Why?
Why is this so hard?
This is easy.
But I can't do it.
It's like fuckin' Inception.
Honestly nobody can speak,
for the foreseeable future.
69 minutes, according to my calculations.
All I could come up with was 320.
I
said two hours.
I said, honestly?
45 minutes.
- [Female Narrator] The
correct answer was two hours.
Ah, aw.
Two hours from now.
Mother sucker.
Oh my God.
What the?
Two hours.
I honestly don't think I could
have done these questions
sober, at all.
Oh fuck yeah I could have.
Really?
No.
Honestly I think alcohol
may have helped me here.
That was eye opening. If I was
in sixth grade I definitely
would not take shots of
tequila before a quiz.
You're the one that's humming
when you do your math.
Did anybody tell you that?
That you hum when you do math
You did
Literally you did.
(soft music)